the house today passing the massive 1.9
trillion dollar coronavirus relief
package
president joe biden is expected to sign
it
friday key parts of the bill include
stimulus check to most americans and a
boost to federal unemployment benefits
through
august it also spends billions to help
reopen schools
they better get a move on that it's
almost spring break
and provides aid to small businesses it
also includes more money to develop and
distribute vaccines
but but but the bill passed without a
single republican vote why
well because of what else was in this
covid relief bill
86 billion to bail out pension programs
500 million to fund arts programs
35 billion in obamacare subsidies
and 1.5 billion for amtrak
why because
the simple question here what does
any of that have to do with covid and
the pandemic
here to help me understand things better
as he frequently did when we worked
together
the house minority leader from the great
state of california kevin mccarthy hey
kevin how are you
i'm doing well trey my mom's watching
she says hi
and your hair looks pretty good tonight
she wanted to make sure he knew that
you i hope my mom says that you tell
your mama hello for me
i will i know you're in the minority
what's in this covered relief bill
that that you find your mom or my mom
might find most alarming in a coveted
relief bill
well first of all it's not a coveted
relief bill this is a bay area bailout
less than nine percent of almost two
trillion dollars
goes to covet and remember trey there's
a trillion dollars sitting out there
that we've already passed before
that hasn't been allocated you talk
about money for schools
but two-thirds of that money can't be
given to schools until 2023
but let me tell you what it does do you
know there's only nine percent for
covent
but it gives san francisco it takes care
of their 650 million dollar deficit
because it gives them 600 million
dollars
now you know why this city has a deficit
if you're a homeless person in san
francisco
they'll buy your alcohol and your
marijuana it gives
federal employees up to twenty one
thousand dollars
not not those in the private sector but
twenty one thousand it gives state
employees
up to twenty five thousand dollar bonus
i mean everything you read about this it
rewards
bad behavior for those reckless cities
and states they get rewarded
california has a 10 billion dollar
surplus
but they're getting money it is just the
wrong bill at the wrong time
too costly and too liberal
i guess if you call it coveted relief
you can put whatever you want in it let
me ask you quickly about another bill
hr1
what is in that bill that should alarm
viewers
well the first thing the viewers should
pay attention to is the number itself
hr1
that's reserved for the most important
issue for the majority
so the democrats chose not something
that helped the people
but to help themselves this is about
making the elections national
you can't have voter id it makes sure it
politicizes the campaign for the federal
election commission where
right now it's bipartisan same number of
republicans and democrats
but no let's wait make sure it's more
democrats but the most egregious thing
here
let's say aoc someone gives her two
hundred dollars
well then they're saying now the
taxpayer should now give aoc
1200 they should match that six to one
that is what they're trying to do to
guarantee that they are re-elected
absolute power corrupts absolutely and
we're seeing it in hr one
and that was the first bill they
reserved the number one for that first
bill all right i think you're headed to
the border
uh what is biden's immigration plan it
doesn't have any border security does it
no you know i was going to go to the
border to see the wall but
all i have to do is look out the capitol
that has the biggest wall with the
barbed wire and everything else
down on the border he stopped the any
wall from being built
he is now taking away for anybody who
wants to come across and
look at this you understand this well
with your time in congress
in the last month there was a hundred
thousand
immigrants arrested trying to cross a
hundred thousand
that is more than the population of joe
biden's hometown of scranton
that was just in one month i'll promise
you based upon what biden is doing by
opening up the border and not opening up
the schools
there's going to be a million people on
the other side of the border coming
across
next month kevin we got about 30 seconds
i want to congratulate you on doing
something you've been a great friend of
mine for
for a decade now most of us read the dr
seuss book 50 years ago i think you read
it maybe for the first time
this week i saw a picture of you reading
a dr seuss book and i want to
congratulate
you for that and i'll give you five
seconds to respond and tell me how wrong
i am
look every year i get asked in my
schools to do read across america
and i couldn't be there because we're in
sessions so i read it online
it took me a few years after you were
able to read it the words were pretty
big took me a while to sound them out
thank you brother i'll call you and
we'll finish it all right